first of all
can you actually zoom out even more like
because you mentioned ion
production engine is a subset of
electric
so like maybe is there a categories of
electric engines and then we can zoom in
on
ion propulsion yes so sure there's
um the two most kind of conventional
types that have been around since the
60s
are ion engines and hull thrusters
and ion engines are a little bit simpler
because they don't use a
magnetic field for generating thrust
and then there are also
some other types of plasma engines but
that don't fit into those two categories
so
just kind of other plasma like a
vasomere
engine which we could get into
and then those are probably the main
three
categories that would be fun to talk
about oh and then of course the category
of engine that i work on which is um has
a lot of similarities to an ion engine
but
could be considered its own class called
a colloid thruster
colloid cool okay so what is an ion
propulsion
i imagine okay so in an ion engine you
have
an ionization chamber and you
inject the propellant into that chamber
and this is usually
a neutral gas like xenon or argon
so you inject that into the chamber and
you also inject
um a stream of really hot high-energy
electrons
and everything's just moving around um
very randomly in there and the the whole
goal is to have um
one of those electrons collide with one
of those neutral atoms
and turn it into an ion so kick off a
secondary electron
and now you have plasma yes okay
and now you have um
uh and now you have a charged you know
xenon or argon
ion and and more electrons and so on um
and then uh some fraction of those
ions will happen to make it to this
downstream
electric field that we set up between
two grids with holes in them
and you know in terms of area the same
amount of those ions also makes runs
into the walls and lose their charge and
that's where some of the inefficiencies
come in but the very lucky
few make it to those holes in that grid
and
there are two grids actually and you
apply a voltage
differential between them and that sets
up an electric field
and a charged particle in an electric
field creates a force
and so those ions are accelerated out
the back of the engine
and the reaction force is is what pushes
the spacecraft forward
um if you're you know following along
and tallying these
charges now we've just sent a positive
beam of ions out the back of the
spacecraft um
and and for our purposes here the
spacecraft is neutral
so eventually um those ions will come
back and
hit the spacecraft because it's a
positive beam so you also have to have
an external
cathode um producer of electrons outside
the engine
that pumps electrons into that beam and
neutralizes that so now it's net neutral
everywhere and it won't come back to the
spacecraft so that's that's an ion
engine
what temperature we're talking about
here so in terms of like the
the chemical based engines those are
super hot uh you mentioned
plasma here how hot does this thing get
um
i mean is that an interesting thing to
talk about in a sense that is that a
interesting distinction or is the heat i
mean it's all going to be hot
no so it's important especially for some
of these smaller satellites people are
into launching these days so the
it's important because you have the
plasma but also those high energy
electrons are hot and um if you have
a lot of those that are going into the
walls you do have to care about the
temperature so
um i i'm having trouble remembering off
the top of my head i think they're at
like a hundred electron volts in terms
of the electron energy and then i'd have
to
remember how to convert that into kelvin
can you stick your hand in it
it's that no temperature not recommended
yeah
you